[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
foreign
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
um
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is an example of a hero mission
showcasing hulk's destructive capability
harm challenge rooms are a great place
to hone your combat skills
you can expect heavy resistance
[Music]
you asked for him and we're thrilled to
bring him to you
you so much and we'll see you in the
beta
yo that was just like the movie
[Music]
is so cinematic like this game is going
to dominate my life
like this is what i want out of this
experience
holy okay i'm ready dude
just give me the game let's give me the
game what
what oh you can wow
oh god the hulkbuster that's amazing
i don't think i can keep up with how
much action it's been thrown at me right
now oh my god this game is everything
i've ever wanted
welcome to our special launch edition of
marvel's avengers war table
we are just days away from launch and
many of you are already playing the game
with early access
that means you could be playing the full
game right now instead of watching this
stream
august was a big month for us millions
of you joined the beta and were among
the first to play our original avengers
story and assemble online with friends
if you played the beta you now know this
game is
huge and we barely scratch the surface
of what's coming on day one
so we're gonna show you everything
you'll want to be doing at launch
we'll also go deeper into the avengers
initiative and operations
which are larger content drops involving
new stories and new heroes
we'll also talk about in-game content
and give you a first look at mega hives
let's get started with what to expect on
day one
day one most of you will want to start
with the full single player campaign to
be among the first to uncover the many
mysteries and secrets in marvel's
avengers
before the spoilers start to appear that
includes playing new origin stories for
key characters like miss marvel and
modoc
and finally finding out the answers to
your burning questions such as
where is nick fury why is hulk all
bruised and bearded
and of course what really happened at a
day
if you want to jump right into the
avengers initiative to begin leveling up
your favorite avenger
in single or multiplayer missions by
starting on day one
you can earn special rewards just for
our players at launch
and you can access the avengers
initiative and play in parallel with
your campaign
so you can go play with your friends and
then come back and pick up
right where you left off from the moment
you touch the game
starting with everyone who joined the
beta you are influencing the future of
marvel's avengers
we've been working hard to address your
feedback so far and will continue to do
so
day one means being the first to find
marvel's avengers secrets
and this game is brimming with
fanservice
that includes locations personalities
easter eggs and a countless number of
references for you to discover
and connect to some of our favorite
moments from marvel's history
an iconic company that now has 81 years
of iconic content as of its birthday
yesterday
august 31st happy birthday marvel
marvel's avengers has great daily and
weekly gameplay loops
and understanding these is an effective
way to maximize your time playing
there are daily and weekly content
resets and the war table
is also dynamic some missions and
rewards cycle in and out during your
play session
some rotate daily while others will only
appear over the weekend
like in secret lab which we'll talk
about in a little bit
here's another pro tip there are two
factions each with eight assignments and
one villain sector per day
that's almost 20 small objectives make
sure to go grab all your faction dailies
when you log in
because they can be completed as you
play through other missions
in-game vendors are also important to
pay attention to each has an inventory
that rotates once per hour
so there's always something you need to
shop for
cosmetic vendors one of several ways
players can obtain cosmetics
are similar the vendors have a stock of
outfits emotes and name plates that
rotate once per day
you can unlock these cosmetics with
units you earn by opening strong boxes
which are found throughout missions
villain sectors are special missions
that provide epic showdowns in boss
fights that you'll want to keep coming
back to
especially the closer your heroes get to
the game's launch power level cap of
150.
uncover the secret behind these villain
resurgences and put an
end to them if you can
nick fury vanished after heyday but
before that
he set up hidden shield vaults around
the world you can unlock these treasure
troves of resources
weapons and secrets that is if you can
locate their coordinates within a
mission when they appear
a few curious beta players found one of
these secrets
yo lejeune here this is 100 real we have
found a secret vote
mission in mars avengers in the beta
shield vaults are critical to increasing
your readiness for the challenges that
await you on the road to marvel's
avengers endgame
marvel's avengers features more than 50
enemy types inspired by classic designs
from the comics
many of which come directly from the
ranks of advanced idea mechanics
also known as aim aim first appeared in
strange tales 146
and their twisted science and quest for
global domination has made them an arch
enemy of the avengers ever since
our team has created our own take on
everything from ames emblematic
beekeepers
who wear special suits to prevent
contact with the natural world
to adaptoids technologically advanced
robots imbued with superpowers harvested
from
heroes and in humans rounding out their
arsenal is the monotronic exo
aims first foray into exosuits we took
heavy inspiration from this design from
quintronic man a five person exosuit
developed by aim that first appeared in
the incredible hulk 213.
by leveraging aims cutting-edge
technology even human soldiers can stand
toe to toe against the avengers
but aim isn't the only threat you'll
face the watchdogs are a human terrorist
organization
built up in opposition to the perceived
inhuman threat
in the comics this dangerous group first
appeared in 1987
in captain america 335 they despise
any form of enhanced human so aim is a
natural ally for them to help eliminate
all superpowers from the face of the
earth
with all of this available at launch
you're definitely going to want to be
among
the first players to assemble your team
and share the experience from the very
start
and what's available on day one is truly
only the beginning
as you play through the reassemble story
campaign you're actually completing the
prologue of a much larger arc
beyond day one the avengers initiative
is at the heart of this larger world
here you can continue to hone your team
while playing through an interconnected
series of stories
missions and personal hero arcs some of
these have a more immediate and ongoing
impact on how you'll play
like events events are one way we're
keeping the avengers initiative fresh
and new
some events will take place over a week
and others will be seasonal
some will have cosmetics and gear that
are only available to earn for a limited
time
getting in from the beginning ensures
you are there for all of them
no one wants to miss out on their
favorite outfit right
we're also adding new locations to
explore like shield substation zero
shield substation zero is a brand new
outpost for the resistance
led by none other than commander maria
hill available shortly after launch
the substation opens up as a social
space after temporal anomalies begin
forming across the world
you'll have to help maria hill
investigate the source of these
disturbances
known as tachyon rifts but will save
getting into those missions and the
special gear you can earn from them for
another time
the more you play the more you'll want
higher level missions to conquer
like heinz and ames secret lab
for the pinnacle in marathon challenges
at launch behold
the mega hive a weekly mission type mega
hives will put your full
roster to the test as you fight your way
through a gauntlet of descending floors
packed with enemies the farther you go
the higher the difficulty goes up
when one hero falls the next in your
roster taps in
but once all your heroes are defeated
you'll have to start over from the very
beginning
how far can you go into mega hives aims
secret lab is one of the truest
tests of endgame team play it's a
mission you can't even access until
you've reached the upper end of power
level caps
it requires advanced tactics and the
full cooperation of a seasoned
four-player team
the lab culminates in a massive boss
fight that is influenced by how you
performed throughout the mission
secret lab is only available once a week
and must be completed within a set time
window
the avengers initiative will also evolve
over time with the addition of new
heroes
villains regions and gear for years to
come
each of these editions combine and build
over time to a much larger series of
story arcs
we've previously talked a lot about
missions but now let's take a look at
operations
starting with a new hero story that we
can't wait to tell you about
avengers good there's someone who wants
to talk to you
i believe some of you know kate bishop
oh we've met
are you working for shield now it's uh
complicated
where's clinton that's complicated too
clint and i were looking into what
happened to director fury after a day
we stumbled on this tachyon project and
then clinton was gone too
what the hell is that our guest finally
agreed to help
remember what's riding on this easy duck
deal's a deal
i'll do my part
we need to destroy
okay how's this i am thor god of thunder
that is not what i sound like
taking aim is the first big post-launch
operation
it directly advances the story starting
at the conclusion of the reassemble
campaign
we are so excited to share that the
first avenger to join our expanded
roster
is kate bishop we love kate
she's smart incredibly talented and
a master archer given the strong
connection and friendship between kate
and clint
we knew we couldn't do one without the
other taken together
we like to think of their individual
hero operations as a double feature
for some background clint the original
hawkeye took on kate as a protege
but in many ways kate is the mature one
she's like the smarter younger sister
who has to clean up the messes of her
reckless older brother in the taking aim
operation
you'll get a new hero kate bishop
complete with her own set of skills
gear and moves to unlock and master just
like the core launch heroes
you'll also get a brand new story and
villain that adds to the ever expanding
avengers initiative experience
while operations are a way to introduce
new heroes villains
and more story they can also add new
regions to the globe
these larger expansions combine to form
new arcs
and lead to large-scale confrontations
that continue to push your team to grow
and improve
well past the reassemble storyline we'll
have a lot more to share about
kate and clint in the future marvel's
avengers is an
epic experience ready for you to dive
into on day one
you've seen the beta you've seen what's
coming day one you've seen what's coming
after launch
the journey has just begun players can
jump into this world today
join us assemble your team and take your
first steps into marvel's avengers
in our next war table you can be the one
telling the stories
we'll recap where launch has taken us
where we're going next
and showcase the amazing feats of
heroism you've performed
so please send us your coolest clips
show off your best builds
your favorite hero customizations and
your strongest online co-op team
maybe we'll feature you in our next war
table we can't wait to show the world
what you're doing
thanks again for believing in us and
always telling us what you think
we're listening and committed to making
marvel's avengers your favorite
superhero game for years to come
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
you